hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the magnus crossing chester
it's match three
and it's uh well it's games uh game five
of the magnus cross and versus hikaru
nakamura matchup
so what happened in the first four rapid
games first magnus took the lead in game
one then game two ended in a very quick
draw
as magnus also went for a quick draw in
the berlin with the white pieces
then game three ended by hikaru
equalizing the match
the game that we've skipped we're going
to show this game tomorrow as it's again
a really complicated game and i really
want to
do it uh well tomorrow when i will have
a bit more time
and then the fourth game also of the
rapids ended in the draw and then this
is the first game of the blitz which is
just incredible
it's uh well it's an absolute privilege
to show you this game because it's uh
yeah i don't i don't think we've had
a game with so many awesome lines uh for
for quite a while now it's so it's a
blitz game the rapid section is over two
more blitz games before we go into
armageddon or before the match is
concluded
in the blitz section so let's check it
out nakamura with the white pieces again
goes for e4
uh sorry about that uh and again we will
have a nice uh berlin defense discussion
with e593 knight to c6 and bishop to b5
so the rule is once again on the board
knight f6 and the d3 so
repeating the line bishop to c5 and now
captures on the
on c6 uh we have d captures and the
knight b to d2 so preparing to shoot the
knight to c4 like in every game so far
castles uh by uh by magnus
and now comes queen to e2 so a bit of a
different idea than the immediate knight
to the c4
rook to e8 now defending the pawn this
way and now knights the c4
uh we have knight to d7 defending
preparing f6
uh and now bishop to b2 so now the
bishop can also come to c3 to add
another attacker to the e5 pawn with b5
by magnus and the knight
back to e3 now the knight can come to f5
if possible and now
knight to f8 by magnus so now the bishop
also covers f5 so it's not a problem
and here h5 and this position has been
reached
a few times however every time that this
position was reached either a5 or bishop
that b6 was played however
here magnus plays knight to e6 and it is
a new move in the position so he says
uh i'm playing my uh knights to d4 or to
f4 to attack your queen and it's going
to be it's going to be really
problematic and you don't have
you don't have a lot of good ideas here
for example if c3 to prevent minot from
coming here
knight f4 is incredibly dangerous
because it it attacks this pawn it
attacks the queen if the queen moves
then
it also attacks the d3 pawn twice so
not the way uh you want to play this
however
uh magnus missed one idea that hikaru
can play in this position
to really gain a lot of well a lot of
advantage so feel free to pause the
video
and find this idea while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
the e5 can actually be captured and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's knight captures an e5
and when magnus saw this he was not
happy because here you have to calculate
and you have to calculate a lot because
well the idea ideas that you were hoping
to do like uh let's say knight to
f4 uh just attacking the queen let's say
opening up an attack on the knight
doesn't work because white can just play
queen f3 and attack your knight
so not really not really something uh
something great or even instead of this
you can even go for a double attack with
knight captures on c6 you grab a pawn
you grab another pawn and now you don't
care about your own queen being attacked
because you also attacked the uh attack
his queen
so this is one thing that's possible
another thing that's possible let's say
you go knight to d4
now there's an even greater knight
captures on f7 and this is just amazing
so you grab the second pawn and of
course you want to trade queens now
because you also attack black's queen
and after queen f6 there's the uh
incredible well
now it seems like you're losing that
piece but there's the queen h5
brilliant uh because now uh if the queen
goes for uh the knight
then you can capture the bishop on c5
and you're just up in material so
what you would have to do here after
queen to h5 is not capture on f7 with
the queen but rather go
go for knight captures on c2 check
forking the king and the rook
forcing knight captures on c2 to open up
this attack on the f2 pawn
queen captures and now king to d1 and
here
uh well again if you go after the after
the knight the bishop hangs
so you'd probably have to go for queen
captures in g2 but now
knight the h6 check this is uh this is
really really incredible
uh because it came to f8 uh you can just
checkmate the king with queen to f7
brilliant stuff uh and if you don't if
you capture it then it's just
queen captures an e8 with check bishop
blocks and
now comes knight the e3 and here uh
black
just doesn't have uh doesn't have
anything to do it's uh
it seems like black is doing well
because black can actually capture both
of the rooks but
uh if magnus went for this line it's
very much
possible that we would have an immortal
game on our hands like a true immortal
game
because here captures with czech king c2
opens up an attack on the queen
also threatens the to bring the rook
into the game if the queen moves bishop
to b4 will be an idea
so here you can capture the other rook
as well but then bishop b4
and there's nothing you can do uh if
bishop b7 to open up
the attack here and defense queen e6
check will go king a trait now bishop
the c3 check
bishop the g7 you can block this but now
comes captures captures and the knight
f5 check so
all the pieces get utilized king of f8
and now a nice checkmate here with the
queen
so these these are only some of the
possibilities that can happen if
magnus decides to go uh uh for ideas
like knight to f4 or knight to d4
after he carves knight captures an e5 so
uh he
magnus here should have gone for queen
to f6 this is
the best defense and now after he grabs
another pawn you're gonna grab on b2
a white castles and the game continues
he carl would be up upon but magnus
uh would have the bishop pair and it's a
bliss game you know
anything can happen you just continue
playing however after this knight
captures an e5 move
you can see that we're spending quite a
lot of time on this one move
uh but magnus played a5 and now it's a
problem because now hikaru gets a clear
way into
into the black camp queen to h5 goes
after the f7 pawn so magnus defends it
g6 and now comes queen f3 again
attacking f7
with f6 now by magnus pushing the knight
back and only now
knight captures on c6 with check
queen to d7 attacking the knight here
but now
uh another uh incredible tactical shot
by hikaru queen captures on f6
sacrificing the knight now
uh as you have plans for your pieces to
start attacking you don't you no longer
care about the knight on c6
so here queen captures and now he carl
played bishop to c3
another incredible move was knight the
g4 simply threatening knight to h6
checkmate as the queen
controls these squares however you would
have to calculate that after bishop to
f8
you have knight to e5 attacking the
queen and the preparing queen f7
check h5 is coming and so on for example
if queen d6 you just play queen f7 check
king h8 and
now again you sacrifice the knight
h5 but there's nothing black can do here
it's it's just incredible
for example if uh if you capture the
knight then just h captures on g6 and
that's it
you're getting checkmate checkmated
nothing nothing you can do here if you
try this
and then just queen to h7 checkmate and
it just an incredible position
so after queen captures on c6 we have
bishop the c3 by hikaru instead of this
knight to g4 move
and now rook to f8 magnus needs to start
running away with the king so queen h8
check king of seven and now queen
captures on h7
king the e8 by magnus and now queen
captures and g6 so hikaru just gobbling
up everything
with tempo king the d7 and now
uh of course the the the finisher d4
and the opponent is uh attacked twice
however
hikaru is hoping for bishop captures and
then just a queenside castle to add
another rook into the attack
so magnus tries b4 instead uh
attacking hikaru's bishop as well but he
currently just captures here we have b
captures in c5 and uh he was in this
position on move 22 that
magnus carlsen resigned in the game and
well
he resigned because there is nothing
more to be done here uh
point is that well now your position is
just completely busted the queen side
castle is coming and if you try to win
back a piece with b captures on c3
then just castles and uh the king has
nowhere to go king is seven knight d5
check is coming you have to go under the
under the mask of the rook king the
eighth knight before check wins the
queen easily it's just game over
so after 22 moves magnus resigns and he
car takes the lead in the match in the
blitz section
and i don't know if i will have time to
show you the second blitz game but
all in all i will not mention the result
if anyone's not interested you know
close your ears
uh the second blitz game ended in a draw
which means hikaru
wins the uh wins the third match and
again takes the lead
in this entire match series of sets of
what not so really incredible stuff so
it seems like
today we had a a complete opposite of
what happened yesterday yesterday magnet
uh hikaru took the early
lead and magnus equalized in game three
and then magnus one in blitz and now we
have the the exact same opposite
magnus takes the lead in game one hikaru
equalizes in game three
and then takes the win in the blitz
section without reaching armageddon
and like i said we are going to show the
game three of the rapid section but i'm
going to show it tomorrow as
i will have more time tomorrow so yeah
incredible stuff uh i really do hope you
enjoyed it really really uh
truly and well i mean the game is the
brilliancy 22 moves against the magnus
just uh i mean wow and you can see how
many lines there were
especially that uh crazy line with the
double rook sacrifice
just incredible uh so yeah that's uh the
game i do hope you enjoyed it uh i would
like to thank uh mandy goschall
uh brian powell sandy harris james
morris and russell lloyd for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the finals
cheering up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your sunday
unless it's already monday where you're
at
see you soon